The next doctor strange film, for instance
features some new MCU characters that that
will be making their debut in that movie that you want expect or won't guess who it is,
but we found a cool way to make it work cause we needed a particular, we want to make a particular type of movie
there and there was a character he always
wanted to do something with who we think will
fit really well there you mentioned Spider-Man Civil War you for the stories that it was
always touch and go were we gonna be able to make a deal with Sony or not. it  happened again
recently, but that was happening.
The first time while we were writing and making Civil War as of in game in your opinion, would
be the strongest Marvel hero. as of any game yet for meaningful is one of that change.
Well I think it's interesting if you if you
look at endgame Wanda Maximoff was going
to kill Thanos.
Yeah, I had desperately that's a scare.
As I've ever seen them.
And if he hadn't said decimate my entire team to get her off me.
I think she would've done it, but Disney plus
is the big one right continuing the movies
and and as we've announced. We'll be doing 4 movies starting in 2021, but Disney plus has been
amazing because for the first time we been
able to do service longform narrative storytelling
we been doing that over 10 years, 23 movies but to do it in our six hour epic mega series
whatever we want to call it for Falcon and Winter soldier for Wandavision for Loki and expand the MCU
because those the those tied directly right
from endgame and then go directly into our
next few movies so I think expanding that
MCU experience truly from the the streaming
platform to the screen is is a fun challenge
for us and again 23 movies in 10 years of
Marvel Studios for me almost 20 years of Marvel for me to have a new way of storytelling is
great and keeps everybody most of us tomorrow.
Students have been around 10 years at least.
Looking back, everyone is Charlie so we have a brand-new Marvel phase 4 Doctor strange 2
panel the Kevin Feige just did to break
down he's in a whole bunch of stuff about
a bunch of different movies that are happening during Marvel base for if you're brand-new
to the channel
Be sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's a bunch of really big stuff
happening this year because this is my first
Marvel video of 2020 were doing a new
infinity saga box set giveaway for all those Marvel films.
The big one.
I have an extra copy to giveaway all you do
to enter is be subscriber and your biggest
prediction about Doctor strange to the clip
that I included the beginning of this of Kevin
Feige talk about Doctor strange to Marvel
phase 4 all that stuff is a really shortened
version of a much longer talk that he gave
so we'll just break this down top 10 style
starting with number 10 when he is talking
about how they pick which characters they
introduce next in the Marvel cinematic universe.
He talks about the characters that they're
introducing that they've always wanted to
do inside Doctor strange to just because of
the type of movie they're doing allowed for
these characters and fans would never guess
who they're gonna do so right off the bat.
People like, what's that brand-new awesome huge character there introducing the reason
why I don't think he's talking about Mephisto because that would be an amazing character
to introduce in a really easy slamdunk for
Doctor strange horror film that is whole qualifier
is that fans would never guess that and
Mephisto was the very first guest that the Internet
made collectively, so automatically that probably means that is not Mephisto that he's talking
about.
During this, I don't think he's talking about
nightmare or the Clea character, because the
director Scott Erickson separately a couple
years ago were talking about those characters
so they been on fans radar for a long time.
Typically when you think of Doctor strange
their couple core characters.
The you go to first so it sounds like it's
knocking to be any of those regular characters.
This is sort of like then doing egos a living
planet and guarding to the galaxy volume 2
it's a really deep cut comic book character
you never thought that they would do but then
also making him Peter quills father.
My guess is that it won't be quite as big
as people are making it out to be ill just
be some super weird deep cut character that will wind up being a really cool thing during
the movie, but not nearly as big as what it
seeming to be made out to be number 9
he says that scarlet which is the new most
powerful character in the Marvel cinematic
universe at the end of Avengers endgame just to be clear, I think he was only referring
to characters that were in Avengers endgame, so he's not talking about other big cosmic
characters.
They haven't done yet because they're way
more powerful characters than scarlet which
that they just have not gotten to yet Galacticus probably the best example that everyone's
waiting for them to do new fantastic four
movie, so that eventually we can get to collect
this and introduce another God tier powerful character into the MCU, but this is Kevin
Feige saying that scarlet which is more powerful than the whole she's more powerful than Captain
Marvel.
I saw a lot of you joking in my timeline about Kevin Feige.
Saying the exact same thing about Captain
Marvel last year before her movie came out.
I believe his quote about her was she's the
most powerful character we've ever introduced
in the Marvel cinematic universe and that
was before Avengers infinity war.
It happened so I think the logic is sort of
whoever is getting the next big movie in they
want to hype up they think it might be big.
That new person is the new most powerful character in the MCU so somebody will come along like they'll
do their Silver surfer movie and say,
He's the most powerful character we've ever introduced into the Marvel cinematic universe.
He's nothing if not a hype man, so hopefully that kind of explains the way they feel about
how powerful each of their characters are
as of right now that's true scarlet witch
is the new most powerful avenger character on planet Earth number eight Wandavision
is now releasing in the fall this year instead
of 2021. because it's New Year's week 2020.
As I'm releasing this video, Disney plus released a new trailer.
Hey, here's all the cool stuff or releasing
during 2020 everybody get hyped up.
There was a clip for the Mandalorian season to because that's gonna be coming out later
this year.
Everyone's really excited about that, but
they also included a clip for the Wandavision series
So people were like wait a minute, what about the Marvel phase 4 timeline that you showed
off at D23 that had it coming out during
spring 2021 before Doctor strange 2. So just
to be clear, the Wandavision series is going
to cross over with Doctor strange 2 the reason
why it used to be coming out right before
Doctor strange to is because the final episode
of Wandavision will basically be the opening moments of Doctor strange 2 because scarlet
witch is going to be in Doctor strange 2
as a main character, so that the TV shows
and the movies will truly be one shared universe in a way that they've never been before.
It's all connected only for real this time.
You have also spotted the Easter egg from
behind the scenes on Wandavision.
They been filming they're actually going to
be doing sword from the comics, so the shield
of the Marvel universe now becomes a sword which we all kind of thought at the Spider-Man far from home post credit scene
with Nick fury on the space station that looked a lot
like the sword space station from the comics.
This just confirms that's all going on and
the comic book version of Monica Rambo that
there introducing the adult version will be
a member of sword liaising with Nick fury
in outer space.
So it really hyped up about that the other
more practical reason there releasing it sooner
is just because it'll be ready to go faster.
I think they just got things going faster
than they thought they would, and you have
the Loki series which is also going to take
place right before Doctor strange to the data
one overlap Wandavision and Loki episodes.
Either way, it just means we get stuff faster,
so I'm really excited about that.
Number 7, when he is talking about all
the Disney plus stuff and the Marvel phase 4
shows he also reveals they're doing 4
movies in 2021 most of you already probably
figured out what this means, but it's the
first time they've ever done 4 movies in
one year. It's going to be Shang Chi and the legend of the 10 rings in the beginning of the year
then Doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness in the spring then Spider-Man 3.
They don't have a subtitle for that yet.
Spider-Man 3 homeless and then at the
end of the year it's going to be Thor 4 love and thunder
they're in the middle of making Shang Chi right now they're gonna start shooting
Doctor strange 2 really soon and then Spider-Man 3 will start shooting sometime next summer.
Number six.
He also revealed that a huge actor just flat
out turn them down when he asked them to play
a really big upcoming character.
They're going to introduced in one of the new Marvel phase 4 movies.
My guess is that because they're heading into production on Doctor strange 2 maybe guardians of the galaxy 3
It was a character for one of those movies
potentially a new character in Spider-Man 3,
because that movie is kind of being fast tracked hopefully wasn't Keanu Reeves turning them
down again number five he makes a bunch of Spider-Man jokes about Sony about them
almost not getting the character during Civil War.
Then again, that happening with Sony after
Spider-Man far from home then everything working out
separately,
Tom Holland also talked about a different
version of Spider-Man 3 that they had
pitched to Sony when he was technically out of the MCU for a brief couple weeks that really
didn't last that long before they brought
them back in the MCU after that all happen.
People went back to Tom Holland recently and the like was going on the Spider-Man three,
so it's really exciting were getting ready
to start shooting next year I'm excited about
the story.
It's very different than the one that we pitch
to Sony when we were not inside the MCU, but
it will be more in keeping with what fans
were expecting from Spider-Man three.
Given the ending of Spider-Man, far from home.
They've also started to acknowledge him crossing over with venom.
Eventually, in the future is become more of
a done deal.
Just a question of when that's going to happen.
So number four there is a report that
Sony is now working with Tom Holland to try
and lock him down on an actual cameo of some kind.
During venom to do some sort of Tom Holland, Peter Parker or full-blown Spider-Man appearance
during venom to maybe post credit scene.
Maybe something as small as him being on screen for less than two seconds.
Number three.
He talked about Shang Chi and the legend of the 10 rings introducing other brand-new Marvel
characters.
He didn't say who this would be, but they
said that because they're doing something
of a kung fu movie.
He implied that the characters would be something that they would only be able to do in a movie
like Shane Chee and the legend of the 10 rings so I'm just guessing that it's gonna be a bunch of super
deep cuts from the Shane Chee comics, but because they're doing the Mandarin a lot of
what they're doing will also flow from the
Ironman comics don't be surprised there's
some deep cut Ironman Easter eggs, because it all comes back to Ironman one way or another.
Number two.
He joked about making changes to new versions of Wolverine and Spider-Man.
This was while he was talking about the history of the Spider-Man character and the X-Men Fox
characters how they basically didn't have
control over their own IP.
Mostly, he was just trying to be funny about
Wolverine and Spider-Man, he wasn't saying
that there can introduce some radically different version of Wolverine even though they will
eventually have to recast number one he also talked during this about how they figure
out the endings to their movies and how it
winds up being a group collaboration.
He was mostly using the example of the vendors and game like how they figure out how the
ending was going to be and when did that happen.
According to him, they figured out the ending Captain America getting his happy ending with
Peggy Carter way before they ever broke the story for Avengers infinity war.
They knew the ending before they knew what the other movies are going to be the big things
happening next week in the Marvel universe is they're dropping the next big new mutants trailer
which is technically a Marvel movie
now so of course I'll do a video for that
when it drops, but leave all your video requests in the comments below.
Congratulations to the giveaway winner from my last big Marvel video long Tyler 48.
Please email me on the about page of my channel so I can get your details. everyone click here
for my brand-new Deadpool 3 Ryan Reynolds video and click here for my brand-new Mandalorian Season 2
video thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome.
This is the way!